problema número 148 148 nos piden
determinar cuál es el dígito de las
decenas del entero positivo x entonces
queremos el dígito dígito
de las decenas de las decenas de s
de x de xy xs entero positivo vale a ver
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que al dividir
x entre 100 queda un residuo de 30 vamos
a ponerlo así x entre 100 residuo
residuo
de 30 pues me parece que aquí podemos
decir que siempre el dígito de las
decenas es igual a 3 por ejemplo qué
tipos de números tienen residuo de 30
cuando los dividimos entre 100 pues el
30 es uno de ellos el 130 es otro de
ellos el 230 en realidad cualquier
número de la forma pues algunos dígitos
algunos dígitos y que luego termina en
30 justo dejar residuo 30 al dividirse
entre 100 y por lo tanto el dígito de
las decenas siempre es 3 entonces la
información del inciso 1 si es
suficiente para responder esta pregunta
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 el
inciso 2 dice que al dividir x entre 110
el residuo el residuo da 30
de 30 o sea que x entre 110 el residuo
de 30 y en este caso me parece que no no
podemos decir gran cosa se parece mucho
al de arriba pero ahora este 110 mueve
un poco las cosas por ejemplo 30 sigue
siendo un número que al dividirse entre
110 deja residuo 30 pero hay otros más
como como 140 como 250 todos estos 360
si le vamos sumando de 110 en 110 nos
dejan un residuo de 30 y el dígito de
las escenas pues quién sabe verdad ya
está raro aquí es 3 aquí es 4 aquí 5
aquí es 6 y así sucesivamente entonces
éste no nos permite decir nada acerca
del dígito de las decenas y por lo tanto
la respuesta es
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 149
en el problema 149 nos dicen que x y y z
son enteros positivos al parecerle ser
les encantan los enteros positivos a los
del yin más positivos
son enteros positivos y lo que
necesitamos determinar es si x
es impar es impar
impar bueno pues si x jay-z son enteros
no importa que sean positivos o no para
que x menos sea impar x 10 deben tener
distinta paridad porque si ambos fueran
pares para - parecería para pagar menos
par
spar
y si fueran ambos impares impar menos
impartan bienestar pero si si son 1 y 1
pues para menos sin par e impar menos
para cualquiera de estas nos da impar
impar entonces básicamente nos están
preguntando si tienen distinta paridad
vamos a ver qué nos dicen las opciones
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que x es igual
a z al cuadrado x es igual a z al
cuadrado pues esto no tiene nada que ver
con ye verdad aquí no tenemos nada de
esperanza de saber si x - sporting park
si x es lo que sea que puede ser 0 o 1 y
entonces nos quedan diferentes
variedades entonces esto de aquí no es
suficiente y el inciso 2 dice que ya es
igual a z menos 1 c está menos 1 al
cuadrado y aquí pues este inciso otra
vez por sí mismo es muy similar al de
arriba no dice nada de x sabiendo esto x
puede ser prácticamente lo que sea
verdad y no podemos pues determinar cuál
es la paridad de x - pero si combinamos
los dos entonces si tenemos buena
tenemos uno pues una suficiente cantidad
de información deja le pongo que por
separado no pero si los combinamos
observa que sucedió
si se está fuera par x sería par porque
un par al cuadrado es par y z menos uno
sería impar y eso elevado al cuadrado es
impar entonces x sería par y yesería
impar y serían de variedades distintas
así que la resta sería impar y qué
sucede si zeta es impar
si se está es impar x sería impar porque
impar a al cuadrado es impar z menos uno
sería par para el cuadrado spar entonces
ya sería parte y x
otra vez sería sería inbar porque sería
impar menos par vale quizás hasta
podemos decirlo de otra forma sin tener
que hacer todos los casos a ver déjame
ver si yo creo que si x x menos teniendo
la información de estas dos igualdades
sería igual a zeta cuadrada menos zeta
menos 1 al cuadrado y eso de ahí es
igual a zeta al cuadrado menos estoy
aquí es un binomio al cuadrado nos
quedaría z al cuadrado menos 12 está más
uno y haciendo la resta se está cuadrada
se cancela con zeta cuadrada y esto nos
quedaría igual a menos por menos es más
2 zeta
menos menos por 1 es menos 112 está
menos 1 vale y como z es un entero 2 por
zeta menos 1 es un impase verdad 12 está
es para al restarle 1 nos queda
entonces la respuesta sería c
necesitamos juntar la información de
ambos incisos vamos más para abajo para
hacer el problema 150
150 ok el problema 150 dice que henry
compro tres artículos en una tienda que
estaba en oferta recibió un descuento de
20% del precio original en el artículo
más caro y un descuento del 10 por
ciento del precio original en cada uno
de los otros dos artículos va y la
pregunta es si será cierto que el
descuento total por los tres artículos
excede el 15% de la suma de los precios
originales bueno entonces supongamos que
tenía tres artículos o que los precios
originales de los artículos eran a b y c
y que estaban en orden de más caro a más
barato
entonces a mayor que b mayor o igual que
se si sabemos que hay uno más caro
nosotros pues puede que tengan el mismo
precio pero digamos que ves el segundo
más caro y se es el quizás más barato
vale bueno entonces el descuento que
recibió en el más caro fue 0.2
el descuento que recibió en los otros
dos fue 0.1 más 0.1 ve más 0.1 c
si porque esto es el 20 por ciento 10% y
10% y lo que nos están preguntando es si
este descuento excede excede el 15% de
la suma de los precios originales y más
ve más ce aquí sí conviene simplificar
un poco esto porque se ve muy complicado
pero creo que se puede reducir algo
mucho más sencillo observa 0 puro
0.15 lo voy a restar de ambos lados de
modo que del lado izquierdo nos quedaría
0.05
si es 0.2 a menos 0.15
y lo demás lo voy a pasar al lado
derecho vaya voy a restar 0.1 b y 0.1 c
de ambos lados de este lado se cancelan
y acá nos quedaría 0.15 b menos 0.1 b o
sea 0.05 b
y algo similar para hacer 0.05 ce
entonces esta condición extraña se
traduce a esta de acá en la cual
identificamos muchos 0.05 entonces
podemos dividir entre 0.05 de ambos
lados de modo que ésta se reduce a una
todavía más sencilla que es a mayor o
igual que ve más vale ok esto está
padrísimo en el simat conviene esto de
de preguntarse si conviene más primero
ver los incisos o intentar reducir la
expresión que nos dan algo mucho más
sencillo vale creo que aquí combino más
esto de reducir bueno vamos a ver qué
nos dicen en el inciso 1 la pregunta
sería ahora ésta
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que el precio
original del artículo más caro fue de 50
o sea es igual a 50 y nos dicen que el
precio original del siguiente artículo
más caro fue de 20 entonces b es igual a
20 y entonces pues se es menor o igual
que 20 verdad porque b es mayor o igual
que c entonces con esta información
podremos determinar que esta igualdad sé
que esta desigualdad se da pues sí
verdad lo que tenemos que ver es que 50
le gané a 20 más ce y aunque no sepamos
el valor de ce lo que sí sabemos es que
es menor o igual que 20 entonces el lado
derecho siempre es menor o igual que 40
y por lo tanto el lado derecho de más
siempre es menor o igual que 50 osea que
a y por lo tanto se cumple esto así que
el inciso 1 si fue suficiente y en el
inciso 2 lo que nos dicen es que el
precio original del artículo más barato
fue de 15 que se fue igual a 15
y esto de aquí por sí mismo no nos
permite responder nada acerca de de esta
desigualdad verdad porque únicamente
vamos a conocer el precio de cee y no se
podrían pasar cosas raras a lo mejor a
lo mejor b es igual a 16 y ya es igual a
17 en cuyo caso pues no es cierto que a
sea mayor o igual que la suma de estos
dos o se puede ser 15 b igual a 16 y a
igual a 170 cualquier cosa verdad aquí
tenemos bien poquitas restricciones y
ahora si a le gana a ve más c muy bien
entonces este de aquí no es suficiente
para responder la pregunta y por lo
tanto la respuesta sería a le dejamos
hasta aquí y continuamos en el próximo
vídeo